hey little guys my name is the Cherno
and welcome back to my sequel club
series I'm back home in Melbourne now so
no more crazy hotel rooms or anything
minutes to go to call this studio and
today when we told me about a raid in
super Club
so before we start talking about a raise
it's really important that you
understand what pointers are I'm an
entire video based on pointers there
will be a card on the screen or a link
in the description below definitely
check that out first before this video
point is a pretty much debate for
salaried working typify so you
definitely need to understand that so
first of all what is an array and array
exactly a collection or element it's a
bunch of things in a particular order in
our case and tablecloth and arranged
basically a way to represent a
collection of variables is basically a
bunch of variables usually at the same
time in a row the reason is it's so
important and so useful it's because
there are countless times where we want
to be able to represent a whole
collection of data a whole bunch of data
and it just doesn't make sense for us to
create a whole bunch of variables that
really should be grouped together in one
data set because variables need to be
created manually we need to actually go
into the code and specify variables and
give them name whereas sometimes we just
want to be able to store say 50 integers
that represent some sort of data we
don't want to have to specify like
integer number one is number two and so
on all the way to 50 because that first
of all is just like that's just terrible
because that that's just that's
completely unfeasible and unmaintainable
imagine having to set all the variable
to zero you literally have to write 50
lines of code that you set all of your
characters zero manually really really
hard to deal with a lot of variables so
what we want to do in that case is just
use an array to contain all those 50
elements or the same type in this case
integers to make our life much much
easier
so just remember an arrange is basically
like having multiple variables in one
variable we give an array a single name
and through that we can refer to as many
variables as we create a be arrayed with
let's let me do some code and take a
look so defining an array is quite
simple suppose that I wanted an array of
five integers I would simply write any
type that I want the array of I would
then give it a name for example example
and then in square brackets I put how
many I want so we'll just say five and
that's it I now have an array of five
integers I've basically allocated enough
to store five integers now in order to
actually set and access those integers I
can write the name of the array and then
inside square brackets something called
an index and an index is wish variable
inside that array I'm actually referring
to which element I'm referring to so
this is the first one we're going to
write a zero because it raised in
several spots start with zero in some
languages such as Lua they start with
one which is very very weird and kind of
uncommon usually array start with zero
meaning that 0 is the first element and
we can set this like like a look any
other integer because it is just an
integer now whilst there is an array of
integers when we access one of those
elements add a specific index we get the
underlying type of the array which is
just an integer we can set it equal to 2
for example now you can probably notice
here that we allocated space to 5
integers however the first index is 0
which would mean that since we all get
aspects of 5 integers the last index is
actually 4 not 5
because index number 5 would actually be
the sixth element let's set this to
something like 4 I'm going to leave the
other ones unset now reading these is
equally as simple if we wanted to print
one we will just specify which index who
wanted to print like this if we just
specify the actual array and it's just
going to print the memory address of it
because this is actually a pointer type
and as I mentioned when you index an
element inside the array you get back
the underlying data type so in this case
an integer so I kind of course create a
new variable and then copy the value
from the array back into that variable
you can see that the data type here is
just a normal integer if I try and
access an index that is not inside the
array for example I trying to access
example at negative 1 or example at
5,000 call something called a memory
access violation because I'm trying to
access memory that doesn't belong to me
now in debug mode you will actually get
an error method in a crashed explain to
help you debug those problems however in
release mode
you probably want which means that
you've just written into memory that
isn't yours now it's really important
that you actually be careful with this
and make sure that you're always writing
inside the bounds of the array because
if you're not it can cause problems that
can be fairly difficult to debug because
you've just modified memory that wasn't
part
arrey however might be part of another
variable neil source code so you've just
literally gone out and changed some
other variable in your code to something
else without realizing it so just make
sure that you set up safety checks where
needed to make sure that you're not
writing up out of the balance we'll talk
more about this specific problem and
stuff like that in the future
now arrays are really well with for
loops because full of our indexable
loops that go through a particular range
right so if we wanted to set every
single value inside our example array a
full Earth is a really good way of
achieving this without a for loop we
would have to go through all of these
indices and actually accept them
manually and that's how we would achieve
setting everything dessous
however by creating a for loop that goes
through the entire length of our array
which is five and simply accepts example
at I equal to two
what we've done is we've looped through
the entire array meaning we've gone
through index 0 to index 4 since index 4
is the last pointer which eyes less than
5 we could have also written less than
or equal to 4 however so no one really
write code like this and also it'll be a
bit of a performance here because they
are doing a less than and equal
comparison so it has to do that equals
comparison instead of just a less than
comparison so it's almost always written
and less than 5 instead of less than or
equal to 4 if we run this code now for a
breakpoint on our C and get we can take
a look at what this actually looks like
in our memory so I'm going to go up to
this memory view here if you want to
know more about that I made a video on
debugging and pipa plus again a link a
description and a condom screen to that
but everything I'm just going to go to
the memory address of my array so
example is actually a memory address on
time because example is an integer
pointer so I'm going to type in an
example over here and you can see that
what I've got here is my twos in a row
so one of the really important thing
about arrays is that they store their
data contiguously which means they saw
that I in a row so I've allocated space
for five integers meaning I'm literally
going to get one integer after the other
in memory each integer is 4 bytes so
what I've got here is 20 bytes worth of
memory in a row which is divided into
kind of four byte segments not really
divided into four pipe segments however
when we access it through our code and
all that it is for all intents and
purposes divided into four byte segments
even though there's no literal division
so that's what you see over here in this
memory of you you see five 2's which
take up four bytes each because they are
integers now when we access a specific
index by writing example I what it
actually does is a text an offset to
this memory so if I write example at
index 2 it's going to start at the
beginning of the array which you can see
is this memory address here
and it's going to simply add on eight
bytes because each integer is 4 bytes we
want to access element number two which
is its third element since indexing
starts at 0 so element number 2 will be
2 times the size of each element so 2
times 4 in our case which bumps up a
fight forward to this integer over here
so if we write a value to example at
index 2 it will write that portion of
memory now as I mentioned an array is
really just a pointer it's an integer
pointer in this case to that block of
memory which contains our 5 integers
which means that I can actually create a
variable here which is just an integer
pointer and give it the value of example
and you can see that works fine and that
will compile just fine because example
is just an integer pointer now as I
pointed out accessing element number 2
and setting it equal to 5 or something
like that will result in us basically
writing to an offset of 8 bytes from
pointer so this code over here can
actually be rewritten using simple
pointer arithmetic to actually be
pointer plus 2 because we're accessing
two elements forward then be referencing
this and then setting it equal to
something like 6 for example let's move
our for loop up before this and give
this a shot and see what we get I'll put
a breakpoint right over here so if I go
to example which is a memory address of
our array you can see that element
number 2 the third element is set to 5
and then of course
it should be set to second steps let's
head up done as you can see over here
that it was changed to six now I did say
eight bytes however you can see that I
wrote off true for this pointer the
reason I did that is because when you're
dealing with pointer arithmetic so
basically what I'm just adding values
like - - a pointer the number of bytes
that is actually going to add it's going
to depend on the type so in this case
since the pointer is an integer pointer
is going to add two times four because
four is the size of each integer if I
wanted to actually deal with by it
either cast this pointer to a data type
that is just one by large for example at
char and then if I do that I'll have to
add on the eight bytes that I talked
about since I then want to write in an
integer which is 4 bytes not just a
single child which is one byte
once I actually do the plot 8 I would
need to cast this back into an integer
pointer and then of course the reference
that to get my internship so that I can
set it equal to 6 now this is a pretty
wild line of code but let's check it out
when I hit our 5 go to my example you
can see it's set to 5 when I hit f10 you
can see we get the exact same result is
a set of 6 so yes you can get pretty
fancy with this but essentially what I
wrote here is exactly what this indexing
does it's not magic that's how arrays
work they're just a contiguous block of
data and you can you can literally
in-depth them like their word book and
write to a specific page in this case a
specific integer
no I'm going to wrap this up here pretty
soon because I don't want to get too
in-depth into arrays and confuse you
however you can also create arrays on
the Cape we haven't talked about the
staff or the sheet mulch or how memory
really works much I definitely am going
to get to that very very soon Oh for now
similarly to how we can create classes
by using the new keyboard we can also
create arrays by using the new keyword
so we'll make another array here I'll
call this one another this will be an
int pointer and then I'll set it equal
to a new instance where decide that I
want so let's go with 5 again this code
is identical to this code however the
lifetime of difference and this is
created on the stack it will get
destroyed when we reach the end curly
bracket and we get out of this scope
however it is since it's created on the
heap will actually be alive until we
destroy it or into our program and so
you need to actually delete it using the
delete keyword and
if this is an array and we allocated
using the array operator here so we use
the new keyword with the square brackets
we need to delete it using the square
brackets like this as well let's go
ahead and bring back that for loop for
our example we'll set it equal to two
and I'll do the exact same thing for our
other array that's another equal to two
of course I could have a friend this in
a single for loop but let's head up five
so if I type an example over here in my
view I get my five two is in a row and
of course the pie type in another I'm
also going to get the exact same result
so why would you allocate dynamically
using the nuclear web rather than just
creating it on the stack the biggest
example is to do with lifetimes right
because like anything be allocate with
new it will be around until you delete
it but we have a function returning and
you will reign for example you have to
allocate using a nuclear word unless you
toss in mount a memory address by the
parameter or something like that if you
want to actually return an array that's
brand-new already it was created inside
the function you need to use the new
keyword another thing to think about
though is memory indirection basically
what I mean by that is since we're
actually holding a pointer that point is
going to point to another block of
memory which holds our actual array
which results in kind of memory
fragmentation and cache misses and all
this complex stuff till they're
definitely gonna talk about in future
video however I'll show you a quick
example so that you know what I mean if
I create a class over here called entity
and I move my example array over here
I'll also create a constructor which
basically just is my for loop that
initializes all this to two and I'll
make everything here in public if I
create my entity objects like this I'll
get rid of all this other code and hit
f5 if I go to the memory address of my
entity and hit enter you can see that
I've got all my memory right there the
memory address of entity actually just
in line contains all of my twos all of
my daughters however if I go back here
and I push this over here to be credit
on the heat by using a new keyword I'll
run that exact same code you can see
that if I go to the memory address of my
entity I don't see my twos there at all
I see this other memory address which of
course is this pointer now I can copy
this and put it here I'll have to
reverse it because at the end Ian nest
though this will actually be 0
0-7 d5e and hit enter I get taken to my
actual data so there's an indirection
again what we've actually got the memory
address of a week and another memory
address to where our actual array is
which means that when we want to access
this web basically jumping all around
our code first to get to the entity then
to get to the array all that stuff so of
course whenever possible you want to
create your array on the stack to avoid
that because jumping around memory like
that is definitely a performance hit now
there's one more thing I want to mention
I know this is a huge video if you guys
like these kind of massive video then
you have time to watch them but I want
to mention arrays instead of both 11
instead of 11 we've got something called
standard array which is an actual
inbuilt data structure is built into the
11 library a lot of people really like
using it over the raw array that I've
shown you here because it offers a
number of advantages namely being that
it includes bounds checking and it
actually keeps track of the size of our
array one more thing that I didn't
mention is that there's actually no way
to work out the size of our array if we
allocate an array on the heap like this
we've set fire to be 5 and in many other
languages we can actually write
something like example dot size you
can't do that in people but there's no
way for you to actually know the size of
an array now I say no way obviously
there is some way because when you
delete this array the compiler needs to
know how much memory to actually free so
yes there is a way to know about its
compiler dependent it's possibly
sometimes stored at a negative index
inside the erase like index negative one
it depends on a lot of things and it's
very very contrasted basically so you
should never be accessing decide an
array in the array memory itself that's
dangerous if you allocate an array on
the stack so if I write in a and in
science you can find out what it so it's
actually insecured of course it's
allocated on the stack which means
because the stack pointer contains the
offset basically so if you're right
sides of and what you'll actually get is
the size of the array and by so in this
case we have an integer which is 4 bytes
we have 5 of them so we have 25 this
will give you 20 bytes so if you want to
know how many elements are in there you
and by the size of the data type which
is in so this code will actually give
you the account in terms of elements I
like to refer this accounts not size
personally when I deal with with the
word size I'm talking about bytes and
one idea would count we're talking about
number of elements so this will give you
five which is the number of elements
that we've allocated however if you try
the same thing with this example instead
then what you're actually going to get
here is the size of an integer pointer
which is four wide and then you're going
to divide it by five which will give you
4/5 or since this is an integer
it will give you zero or nonzero plane
which is wrong anyway so you can only
use this trick with stack out at arrays
if you had to change this to be exact
out at array like third it would also
work that would also be fine however you
really can't trust it and of course as
soon as you decide to pass this into a
function or anything it becomes an
endpoint err and then you're just
screwed so what you have to do instead
is actually just maintain that sign by
yourself I know kind of stuck in that
sense but it's just that's just how a
pop-up works you have to maintain it
yourself the way that I would write this
code personally is I would declare a
constant size to be five and then I
would put this in here now I love it
this gives us an arrow because you can't
actually do that when you allocate an
array on the stack it has to be a
compile-time known constant half true
with an asterisk because there's a
simple slot and there are ways around
this which we'll talk about in a later
video however this has to be known at
compile time so you have to basically
market a static you can also use a
constant expression here constant
expressions of cyclases have to be
static anyway as you can see another
story for another video this videos
going to have so many turn offs because
we're really going into the juicy stuff
now hope you guys are excited about that
so we'll just make it static and we
don't really need this a big heart
expression so that's really how you deal
with this and that in this case telecoil
is something like example size because
it's dealing with the example array
specifically and then you can plug this
into all of your for loops and all that
stuff to actually notice either your
array that's just what you're going to
do if you use at people have got 11
standard array here on how to offer you
guys how to do that you can just write
FTD array we'll make sure to include
this as well just Inc
which array will give it a name for
example another and we basically have to
give it a type and account if we're now
you'll bracket here it says we need the
type name and the size so we'll write
int as the type comma 5 as the size and
that's it with credit this array and to
fill it up of course we can actually do
another dot size and there we go we have
5 so it's an easier way to deal with
this of course that does have the
overhead because it does all of the
balance checking if you wanted to and
also it actually maintains a size
integer as well which you might not want
so there is a bit of overhead usually
it's worth it so consider using this
we'll have a whole video on how that
actually works and all that drop in when
we finally reached our two structures
and start talking about them but just
something to think about
personally I use raw arrays all time
most people probably do a little bit
faster and I personally don't really run
into many problems with them but again
if you're being super safe and you were
probably coming from another language
you probably do want to use standard
array I'm being completely honest it's a
lot safer to use standard array than raw
arrays however I like to live
dangerously anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did you can
show me by hitting that like button and
if you really want to pull up this
series and see more great episodes like
this then you can go to
patreon.com/scishow know you'll get
access to a whole bunch of rewards for
showing your support there and it really
does help me produce these videos I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]